After solving, we find that x is $10,000 and y is $15,000. Congrats if you got
both of these right. If you didn't, that's okay, too. Follow along with me in
the solution, and then pause it when you find a mistake. Then continue solving,
and see if you can get these answers. Remember, mistakes are okay. And this is
the time that we learn from them. I'm going to rewrite this first equation by
subtracting x from both sides to get y is equal to 25,000 minus x. I did this so
I could use substitution. I think that's the easier choice here. Now I perform
the substitution, then I can distribute my 8 hundredths to both terms. Here's my
first term, 2,000, and my second term, negative 8 hundredths times x. I subtract
my constant term to move every constant to the right. And then that leaves me
with x on the left. I combine my like terms, then I divide by the coefficient of
x. I get x is equal to 10,000 or $10,000 which we invested at 7%. And remember
this is a system of equations. And so we have two variables, x and y. Well we
know if x is $10,000, y must be $15,000, since those two have to add up to
$25,000. And as always, we can check our answers. By plugging in x and y into
both equations, we'll get true statements.